Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up. I knew it.
I knew it.
How are you doing?
>> Same as you. So,
are you sure?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> I hope so. I don't know.
>> Maybe.
>> I think we're in the same boat.
>> Okay. Same boat, same problems,
>> same stuff
and same problems.
>> Same problems. Let's Let's dive into
this.
>> Yeah.
>> This
>> I could get hungry.
>> It was always, you know, you never you
should never touch touch somebody's
plate. That's usually getting them very
agitated.
>> Exactly. There's a lot of plate touching
here.
>> So, let's open with a word of prayer.
>> Our heavenly father, thank you for
bringing us together again once again.
We are here to discuss some important
matters and we want to know what you say
about this subject. So, please help us
in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Now, Martin, when it comes to this
issue, we're not going to put in a
thousand references and this and that.
No,
>> we will quote freely script. We've done
this many times.
>> Many times.
>> Let's just get rid of some
misconceptions.
>> Yes, that's a very important.
>> The modern where does this come from?
>> I think the US health secretary,
>> Department of Health,
>> Department of Health, and they decided,
okay, let's turn it around or
>> let's flip the pyramid. Yeah,
>> let's flip the pyramid. So everything
that was supposed to be or let's say
portions of what was supposed to be at
the bottom of the pyramid, the inverted
pyramid was now translated to the top.
>> Yeah.
>> And some of the stuff that was at the
top or is now at the bottom.
>> Yeah.
>> So we have a pyramid inversion
and this is rather rather fascinating.
So if we look at this pyramid inversion
on our backdrop, we have it as well. And
uh yeah, fascinating.
So you should not eat grains in any
quantity whatsoever.
I see that legumes and rice is also
there at the bottom. Fruit seems to be
uh pushed to the to the narrow portions.
uh vegetables get a little bit of an
elevation and lettucees and things like
that. Then at the top of the pyramid as
your bulky foods, you have the oilrich
foods
and then you have the the meat and the
dairy and uh those poultries and all of
those issues at the top together with
vegetables.
Now modern just from a scriptural basis
shall we start with the scripture? Okay.
Genesis.
>> Okay. Now, let me try and quote the
scriptures freely and you must tell me
if I distort it because distortion is
not a good idea, right?
>> No. In
>> Okay. So, it says, "I give you every
seedbearing plant on the face of the
whole earth and every tree with meat on
it."
>> Sorry.
>> And it it Sorry. Okay. Every tree with
flesh on it.
>> What's the matter with you?
>> Something in my throat.
>> Got a frog in your throat. All right,
let's be more specific. And every tree
with beef and chicken and fish on it.
What's wrong with you?
All right. Purely from a biblical point
of view,
I give you every seedbearing plant. What
is that?
grains and
>> so that would be wheat and barley and
corn and rice and and chia and
>> seed bearing
>> everything that is seedbearing
that and every tree with let me correct
myself there fruit on it
>> that shall be yours for food.
So the highest priority
came from the grains, the seedbearing
plants and from fruit.
>> Yeah.
>> So the first pyramid
had those issues as the highest
priority.
Okay.
Then sin came into the world and
vegetables were added
>> because obviously fruit had now become
seasonal whereas before it was
nonseasonal. It was there every month.
>> And by the way what constitutes fruit?
Every tree with fruit on it. Now some of
the fruits have fleshy portions like a
apricot, like a a peach etc. And some of
them the seed is edible. Yeah. The
inside. And some trees have lost the
fleshy portion and put the more emphasis
on the seed. So you have trees that bear
nuts for example which is a fruit
>> of the tree.
>> Yes. but concentrating on the kernel
inside rather than the fleshy portion on
the outside. So can we say that uh
seedbearing plants the grains and uh all
of these various things in the world and
uh the trees with nuts and fruit on them
that was the original diet of man. So
that should be the highest priority,
right?
>> And then vegetable were added after
transgression because of the
seasonality.
Now everything was not available at uh
throughout the year. The ground was uh
deteriorated.
>> The earth was cursed.
>> The earth was cursed. So it didn't bring
forth what it brought forth first and
then uh the vegetables the plants of the
field were added to augment the diet. So
can we say that the postfall diet was
grains, fruits, nuts and vegetables?
>> Yeah,
>> that was it.
>> Plant-based.
>> It was plant-based diet. That was the
original diet in the Bible.
>> Fine. From that we went to 1,500 years
later. So, humanity subsisted on that.
>> Mhm.
>> They did pretty well, right? They were
very big. They were very strong. They
were very very very illustrious in
everything that they
>> lived for hundreds of years.
>> Yes. And then meat was added after the
flood.
>> Okay. Can we say that during the period
of the Israelites when fruits and things
were available again, God tried to train
them to go back to a more plant-based
environment
>> after um the Egypt?
>> Yes.
>> Taking them back to Yeah, for sure.
>> So, they got used to the diet of the
Egyptians and God put them on another
diet. They were highly pleased with this
new diet, right? They sounded like the
European powers towards Trump.
>> Okay, they sounded like that. They were
grumbling. They were muttering. They
were a mixed multitude. They complained
bitterly
>> and they craved flesh.
So God permitted their craving.
And the second time round when they
grumbled again after a little bit of
death of flesh, they uh had a plague.
>> Yeah.
>> And while the flesh was still between
their teeth,
>> some of them developed this wasting
disease. Right. So the original diet is
the prime diet for humanity.
Good. Now, the pyramid that we had
before was one where the grains and then
the fruits and the stuff were the bulk
of what we're supposed to eat and the
and the vegetables
>> and the dairy and the flesh foods and
all of these were to be limited. Now we
have a pyramid inversion
and we have the dairy and the flesh
foods at the top for the bulk of
consumption. Fruits have been relegated
to the bottom. Nuts are virtually
non-existence.
I see a little bit of an inconsistency
because I see some small fishes at the
bottom and some big fishes at the top.
>> If we can point to that. So, we have
some small fishes and eggs down here
somewhere. And we have some bigger ones
over there. I assume this is tuna or
salmon or some of those. And the oil
rich foods and the oils here are at the
top as well. So, Martin, this is an
inverted pyramid. Now, in some of the
issues, I I wouldn't have a serious
issue. I don't mind if uh vegetables
play a prominent role in the diet.
Could you replace all of these animal
products over here with plant-based
products?
>> Definitely.
>> For sure. If you want to have a
proteinrich diet, then you can just
substitute the protein the animal
protein with um plant protein. There's
you always have the um argument, yes,
but plant protein is not a complete
protein. Will you just just briefly
mention something on that?
>> Correct. Now,
>> is that true?
>> That is true. There's one thing that
seems interesting over here. It seems
that uh refined foods are somehow not on
this on this table, which is a good
thing. So, let's give some credit where
it is due.
>> I think that's maybe where the whole
thing is where the driving driven from
>> the crux of the matter. All right.
Processed food and refined foods. We
don't see much of it here. Although the
bread down here is probably from refined
flour, etc., etc. So, Martin,
this is a very interesting
and a very problematic inversion at the
same time. Yeah,
>> it has some redeeming features and it
has some
spurious features.
Now it's very interesting Martin that as
a result of this this new way of
thinking
there have been voices that the seventh
day adventist approach to health
>> is very dangerous and has caused the
chaos and the disease and the obesity in
the world
>> and the question is is that so or is
that not so? So basically what they are
doing is they're accepting this new one
because it really does gratify the human
pallet. This is what the the mixed
multitude was craving.
>> Yeah.
>> They were craving the leaks and the
onions.
>> That's vegetables.
>> Yes.
>> And they were craving the fatty foods
and the flesh pots.
>> That's what they were craving. Right.
That's it. If you remove that from this
equation,
then you will have another bit of
grumbling
on this earth as well.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, let's look at some of the
things that are being said about it and
let's talk about it.
>> Now, this video that we will have a look
at was recorded by Redacted
and let's give them some credit. They
have some very interesting programs.
They have very indepth looks at certain
situations. But I think here they made
assumptions which are not based on
reality and which need to be corrected.
>> Probably got some information from
sources that
would is probably not the most reliable.
>> Correct. So they have the the original
pyramid down there and you can see that
the grains etc were at the broad base of
the pyramid.
Now they're at the narrow base of the
pyramid and then you had your fruits and
vegetables and then you had the the
animal products and the dairy. So let's
run through some of these statements and
see what we can come up with. Well, this
is a fun story about why we have a food
pyramid and why it has looked like it
has since the early 90s and then
subsequently led to skyrocketing rates
of diabetes. One of the lesserk known
influences behind those guidelines comes
from a small Christian denomination and
its role is rarely discussed. In the
beginning of the show, I asked people to
guess who it was. Uh, it wasn't
Jehovah's Witnesses. It wasn't Mormons.
It is not the Catholics. I'm going to
tell you in just a second. The US
Department of Health and Human Services
along with the Department of Agriculture
this week rolled out this brand new food
pyramid. It's basically an inversion of
our old one. It says that your diet
should be made of mostly healthy fats,
protein and dairy, vegetables and
fruits, whole foods. If you go to
realfood.com, it's a beautiful site
actually. Um, and the government has all
kinds of tips on how to eat real
unprocessed foods low in sugar and other
types of uh processed grains. The old
food pyramid was a-okay with processed
grains, spaghetti, breads, crackers,
even like literally the government was
telling you to make most of your diet
out of crackers. Look down there as
saltines. There's no nutritional value
in that. this that's a way to get
diabetes because it's a constant insulin
spike and have very little dairy and
meat.
>> Okay, almost want to say whoa whoa whoa
what are you talking about. Firstly,
let's make it quite plain that the issue
that she's addressing here is processed
food.
>> Correct.
>> Nowhere ever did traditional Adventism
advocate processed foods.
whole foods. In other words, that which
God had originally placed within the
food should still be available. You can
do things with the food. You can you can
mince it. You can liquidize it. You can
blend it. You can do all of those things
with the food as long as that which was
there originally remains in it in
roughly the same proportions.
So in other words,
what kind of grains should one use?
Unprocessed, unrefined grains.
>> Mhm.
>> Modern molds for example
separate the various components of wheat
into their components. So you have the
endosperm which is the white flour.
>> You have the fiber coming off at one
stage and you have the germ coming off
differently. Now what they use is the
refined flour without the the germ and
without the fiber. Now when you do that
then you affect your gut mo mobility
because the fiber is not there. The
fiber is also a component that clings to
the sugar components like the glucose
>> and holds it back so that you don't get
a glucose surge. So what she is talking
about is refined foods at the bottom of
that pyramid which has never been an an
issue advocated by seventh day
adventists.
>> Yeah.
>> How she can blame this group who is the
longest lived group in terms of
longevity of life on the entire earth is
amazing. So fault number one grains were
part of the original diet. We've just
talked about it in the scriptures, but
the we should advocate whole foods.
>> Whole food.
>> There's another issue and that is the
manipulation of grains.
>> And uh in order to create an environment
where the industry benefits certain
changes, genetic changes, certain
hybrids have been produced which are not
exactly the same as the originals.
Now the originals were designed by whom?
>> God.
>> Are you sure about that, Martin?
>> Yes.
>> Not evolution.
>> No.
>> God. I give you all.
>> Okay.
>> So, I give you every seedbearing plant.
So, if we want to concentrate on foods
that were like the original, then we
should have heirloom grains that are
like the original. Now, which grains are
still like the original?
>> Well, for example, if you go to the
grains that they make bread from, then
it's largely uh wheat flour and rye
flour. Now the original grain
uh was a long stalked grain that could
bear uh quite a head of of of seeds up
to a 100fold from what you have planted.
One producing a head of a hundred and of
course uh with heavy heads and winds and
all of these and modern culture then
these fall over easily. So today we have
the short stalked varieties
and the protein content has changed, the
gluten has changed and all of these
issues. So Martin, what you have is a
somewhat transformed grain that doesn't
have the same balance as the original
ones.
>> So original grains are rye is relatively
unmanipulated and spelt.
>> Mhm. So when I bake bread, I try to bake
it from rye and spelt grains.
And those must be whole foods. They
mustn't be refined so that all the
original fiber is in there.
>> In the old days, you used a stonemill.
>> Yeah.
>> And you put the grains in the stonemill
and everything that was in the grain was
ground together as a unit and that was
then to be used. Now if you do that
today and you want to store the flour
for example then it can tend to become
rancid because the the sperm which is
rich in oils starts oxidizing.
>> So they keep it separate. So today they
send the germ to the cosmetic industry
so that the ladies can put it on their
faces
>> to try and outwit aging.
And instead of eating it because it
contains the essential oils that we need
and the enzymes that are needed for
proper digestion of all of these issues,
they've been removed and the fiber has
been removed and you're sitting with a
refined flour that gives you glucose
spikes.
>> Yeah,
>> as she correctly said. Now, are the
Adventists to blame for for that?
>> We didn't advocate that at all. And did
we did we create the hybridization and
the genetic engineering?
>> I think we'll see now forward that
they're trying to link it. Yes.
>> Yes. Okay. All right. So, let's just
correct that in the first place. So,
when she talks about the base of the
pyramid and she talks about refined
crackers that have no nutritional value
in it, that's not an Adventist issue.
That is a worldly issue that has come
in. Yeah.
>> Uh it why was it recommended? Who ever
thought that it was preferable to eat
breads and pasta as the main course of
your meal and suffer this constant
elevated glycemic spike? Well, this is
an interesting story. Most of it told by
what this is way I learned it through
Jane Buckton's great book, The Great
Plant-Based Con. And I'm going to
summarize it for you, but I have many
times recommended that you read this
book. And here is another time. So, this
is not the only story of how
profitable processed foods came to
dominate the American diet, but it is a
big one. In 1863, a woman named Ellen G.
White said that God gave her a message
in a vision, and that message was that
humans should eat what she called the
Garden of Eden diet. By that, she meant
fruits, nuts, vegetables, and seeds, and
no alcohol, no tobacco, no meat, and
very little dairy. This was part of the
religion she would go out on to found.
It was the Seventh Day Adventist Church.
Did any of you get that right? Anyone in
the chat? Seventh Day. I saw a few of
you did. Now, she founded this church in
Battle Creek, Michigan. One of the
families that would help her establish
the church. The dad was a man named John
Preig
John Preston Kellogg. Do you recognize
that name? You probably do. Now here we
have another confused statement Martin.
>> A few
>> a few uh was she instrumental in the
founding of the church? The answer is
yes. Was she the founder of the church?
Absolutely no.
>> No.
>> No. The church grew out of a massive
movement which was a well it was a
countrywide actually a universal
movement
>> which was the Millerite movement.
And uh this Millerite movement
propagated that the prophecies of the
book of Daniel were coming to
culmination.
And they they thought that Christ would
return at the culmination of the 2,300
day prophecy in Daniel. Now that turned
out to be a mistake because they thought
that the sanctuary that was going to be
cleansed was the earth through the
coming of Christ. But uh Christ did not
return. And then they discovered the the
beautiful study of the sanctuary message
in the Bible which by the way
constitutes a large portion of the Old
Testament
>> and must therefore be relevant and it
has to do with the ministry of Christ in
terms of salvation rather than his
direct coming at that particular time.
There's just one thing that when you
mentioned this now that I just want
people to go and study if they haven't
yet but even that that they got the they
had a mistake in what about it is in is
a prophecy
>> God said in revelation
>> that it will be sweet in the mouth and
bitter in the stomach.
>> Correct.
>> So go and study that. But it's not oh it
was a problem.
>> It was a problem. No, it was it was a
misconception
>> very similar to the misconception that
the disciples had in the time of Jesus.
>> The disciples were convinced that Jesus
would proclaim himself king and ascend
the throne of Israel and it didn't
happen. Instead, he died on a cross.
That was a major disappointment. Mhm.
>> So here there was also a disappointment,
but the disappointment led to a a
cleansing as it were of misconceptions
and a realignment into what is actual
biblical reality concerning the kingdom.
And exactly the same happened there, but
that's another story. So the founders of
the 7th Day Adventist Church were people
that came out of the Millerite movement
from many denominations.
And part of the Millerite movements was
over 200 pastors from different
denominations.
And
serious Bible study led to the discovery
of the doctrines which formed the
pillars of Adventism. Yes,
>> Ellen White was instrumental in that
work and part of that work, but she
cannot be considered the founder.
>> No,
>> but just part of the group that founded
this church.
>> And also important is that 1844 that was
worked out by them studying the
prophecies. She never predicted that.
She never got a vision on that. She only
received the first vision. the December
after
>> correct
>> the October 1844 date.
>> Correct. And it's very interesting
Martin that a lot of emphasis is placed
on Ellen G. White as a false prophetess
>> which is basically what was just said.
>> But what was Ellen White's vision about?
It was the exact same sequence and uh
constitution as we just discussed in
scripture.
>> Yeah.
>> So basically
>> she mentioned it.
>> Yeah. So basically she she was quoting
that the scriptural diet was the best
diet.
>> So anybody who goes against it is not
arguing against Ellen G. White. They're
arguing against scripture. They're
fighting the first words of scripture.
>> And let me just talk a little bit about
Ellen G. Right. Before we carry on
because this is obviously a bone of
contention.
Prophets received visions
or dreams
>> in the Old Testament, right? And when
you read about the prophets, there were
two kinds of visions that people had.
The one was called an open vision
>> and the other one was called a night
vision.
Now the night vision was private and the
open vision was public.
>> And if you read the book of Samuel, the
people had apostasized and the Bible
says there were no longer any open
visions.
>> No.
>> Because of that situation. So open
visions were given either as a
confirmation for the children of God or
even to those that were not in the ranks
of God's people
>> and they were to confirm the authority
of the prophet. So for example,
Daniel had both night visions and Daniel
had open visions. And when you read
about the open visions, one of the open
visions that Daniel had was in the
presence of the Babylonians.
>> And when he saw the visions, they fled.
>> They ran. If you read further in the
Bible, you will find Ezekiel, for
example, had open visions while in the
company of the elders of Israel. They
didn't flee because they knew this
prophet was
>> true.
>> True. and he was in vision and whatever
he said when coming out of vision was
the voice of God.
>> Now there were certain criteria attached
to open visions,
>> biblical criteria,
>> biblical criteria and you can read them
in the book of Daniel.
>> So when a prophet went into vision, he
first became weak and he fell down.
>> Then he was strengthened by God. When
God strengthens you, you become as
strong as Samson for example
and God raised them up and then the
prophet stood
>> and spoke.
>> Yeah.
>> But there was no breath in the prophet.
He didn't breathe
>> and his eyes were
>> open. Those are the criteria. Go and
study them in the book of of Daniel.
They'll tell you exactly how a prophet
went into vision. And this was a message
to the skeptics
>> that this was a supernatural event which
by the way cannot be copied.
>> No.
>> Because nobody can stop breathing and
keep talking at the same time. Now Ellen
White had over 60 open visions
>> in front of people. Some of them in
small groups like in the case of
Ezekiel,
some of them in large groups, some of
them in church meetings, and some of
them in public events with thousands of
witnesses.
And during those events, there were
investigations.
Medical doctors would investigate
whether she was breathing.
And they announced emphatically and
there are numerous eyewitness accounts
even in writing that she never breathed
while in vision but she spoke.
>> Yeah.
>> Now that is impossible. It was also
impossible to restrict any of her
movements. The strongest men could not
move a finger of this frail little lady.
So she was strengthened by God. She
would hold a big Bible in her hand on
more than one occasion. On one occasion
for six and a half hours, which is
physically impossible for anyone, at a
45 degree angle at which no Bible can
sit in your hand. It would slide off.
And she would open it away from her,
looking away from it, and point to
certain quotes. People would get onto
chairs, look at it to see whether she
was quoting correctly. and she was
quoting correctly. On other occasions,
she would take from a table where there
were Bibles and she would do the same
and bring it to a person who had a
problem and point to the Bible verse
where they were wrong. These were open
visions
>> that were there for public consumption
with witnesses. In other words, what God
was saying publicly before thousands of
people, this is my voice. I am speaking
through this person. This person is not
breathing. This person is not dead. This
person is alive. I'm keeping her alive.
She doesn't need breath when I speak
through her. And I want you to take note
that I have chosen this particular
individual to bring a message to the
world.
>> And that message will be in harmony with
my scripture because to the law and to
the testimony. If they speak not
according to this word, there's no light
in them.
>> Yeah.
>> So 66 times
public open visions. Does God want to
tell the people something?
>> Definitely.
>> Did they all accept it with joy? No.
Wasn't that the same fate of all the
prophets?
>> Ezekiel, Jeremiah, Isaiah, same.
>> So Martin, by the fruits, you will know
them. Go and check out the fruits. go
and see whether what she says is in
harmony with the scriptures.
>> There are more scripture quotes in her
writings than anything else.
>> And if in any way they should supersede
the scripture then set them aside
because the scripture is the basis. When
God spoke through Jeremiah,
was he negating his scriptures?
>> Not one iota.
>> Not one iota. No.
>> So was Jeremiah speaking according to
the law and to the prophets? Yes.
>> So when she just quoted that this lady
had a vision that grains and fruits
should be the most important component
of the diet, was she contradicting
scripture?
>> No. 100% Genesis.
>> Was she just contradicting scripture by
saying that it was not from God?
>> Yep.
>> I'm afraid so. Let's continue.
>> The dad was a man named John Preig
John Preston Kellogg. Do you recognize
that name? You probably do if you've
ever been in an American supermarket.
Kellogg had 11 children. One of them,
John Harvey Kellogg, as a young man was
given a job to type set the books of
Ellen White. And so her Seventh Day
Adventist books and her temperance
movement were what he would type set.
And back then, this is the 1800s, you
had to letter by letter. Though he was
clearly reading the books and heavily
influenced by the temperance movement,
the temperance reformers believed that
citizens were plagued by disease because
of over stimulation and immoral
behavior. So they set out to curb these
things by abstaining from alcohol and
meat, processed
I lost my way. I was going to say uh oh,
okay. uh by from abstaining from a
alcohol and meat and practicing sexual
restraint and promoting a balance
between exercise, rest and cleanliness.
Uh they were also very big on preventing
masturbation. John Harvey Kellogg also
types set books on that subject too that
told mothers that it was their
responsibility to stop their sons from
masturbating or else they would suffer
from headaches, weak backs, uh spinal
illnesses and blindness. That's where we
get that joke that if you do that you'll
go blind that came from the temperance
movements. They literally said this in
books. So books about this movement
would influence Kellogg and it would
become his life's purpose which
motivated him to make these bland
tasting cereals and prov and prescribe a
vegetarian diet. By 1882 he invented the
cornflake and by the early 1890s he
would bring it to market with his
brother Will. He actually invented more
than just breakfast cereal. That was
just their most profitable. He had a
whole line of pat he had over 30 patents
including the first veggie burger. Now
the question is Americans at the time
were not eating this. Why would they
choose to why would you want why would
you want to eat this instead of bacon
and eggs that they were eating? Well,
>> all right. Let's first have a few
corrections.
The writings of Ellen G. white.
She had helpers that helped her put
together. And the helper that originally
helped her with some of these issues was
her son Willie White. And there were
ladies that helped in the transcribing
of what she had written by hand into a
proper format.
uh Kellogg was one of the principal
medical practitioners that put into
practice what was being said.
>> All right. Now, she said basically that
this whole temperance movement and the
abstaining from alcohol and all of these
issues were 7th day Adventist inventions
>> in a rather derogatory way. I would like
to correct her on that because the
temperance movement was actually a
Methodist movement
>> and that was one of the reasons why the
Methodists were rather illreated by many
parties because they preferred their
ways of life and their alcohol and all
of those issues. So the temperance
movement began long before 7th day
adventists and that is why they called
them Methodists.
>> It was actually a
>> mock a mocking a derog derogatory
statement towards them.
>> Absolutely. So you think you have a
method to get to heaven.
>> Basically that's what they said. So the
temperance movement was a very strong
movement and a large portion of the
people that constituted the beginning of
the 7th day Adventist church came from
the Methodist movement.
Uh the main denominations that were
responsible in the formation or were
part of the formation of the Adventist
church were the Baptists, particularly
the seventh day Baptists and the
Methodists.
>> Presbyterians, not so many.
uh Presbyterians, well, they have, you
know, the doctrine of uh selection
>> and the doctrine of the the kingship of
of the people of Christ. So they were
basically
uh like dominionists, you know, they
will rule, the state will rule together
with the church, etc., etc. So the
tempance movement didn't start with
Adventists. Yes, they took it further
and yes, Ellen White did receive health
visions and they contributed to this
>> and Kellogg was a brilliant doctor.
>> It was brilliant.
>> And also she mentioned the tasteless
corn flakes. That's a important thing
that we have to get to.
The original
corn flakes and all these products
doesn't contain all the garbage that
you've got in it now.
>> No. And this is a very important point.
Now, she spoke about sugar. She actually
said it was tasteless.
>> And yes, Kellogg wanted to add some
sugar to make it more tasty. But one of
the visions of Ellen White says that
sugar clogs the system.
>> She was against it.
>> Yes.
>> So maybe it's important to bring it in
here.
>> Now let me say why it clogs the system.
>> Okay. Go do that and then we can do the
second point.
>> Yes. Because this is a very important
point.
When you have refined sugar in your in
your diet, in other words, you don't
have a whole food diet, you don't have
the grains, you don't have the grains
with their fiber and all of the issues
in that make it an unrefined food, then
you get a glucose spike. So, refined
flour will give you a glucose spike.
Sugar will give you a glucose spike.
Now, how does the body react when you
have a glucose spike? The body reacts by
trying to protect itself so that that
sugar doesn't rush into the blood.
>> Now sugar is water soluble
>> and it is not as readily fat soluble
because it has all of these hydroxal
groups which make it very compatible
with water. So one of the ways in which
the body tries to protect itself against
a glucose surge is by releasing
triglycerides into the blood fat.
>> And this fat basically lines the the
blood vessels
>> and retards the speed at which the sugar
can enter into the tissues around. And
that of course if the sugar surge is
there then you will get an insulin surge
and you will have hypoglycemia
thereafter etc etc. So all of these
issues are important. When I was
conducting experiments at the
university, I always get my students uh
give sugary drinks to let's say a rabbit
and then we'd measure the parameters
that increased as a result of a refined
sugar uh like for example a soda drink
that is rich in sugar.
And you will find that very shortly
thereafter you have the glucose spike
and then you have a triglyceride spike.
And if you add the combination milk and
sugar,
>> that's the worst.
>> Now, then you've added triglycerides to
your diet in the milk because it's very
high in in those fats. Plus, you get a
glucose surge, plus you get a
>> a triglyceride surge because there's no
fiber in any of that.
>> And then that sugar and that uh fat
remained at a very high level. Now that
changes the viscosity of your blood
>> and uh that is a cardiovascular
problem waiting to happen.
>> So you know Martin when Kellogg said we
want to add sugar uh the spirit of
prophecy said sugar cloaks the system it
shouldn't be used as a refined food.
>> So when God puts sugar into something
then he adds fiber
>> it's in a package. Yes, you get two
kinds of fiber.
>> You get soluble fiber and you get
insoluble fiber. The soluble fiber is
the one that binds the sugar
>> and keeps it at bay. Interesting. The
the uh other fiber gives the motility to
the gut, but it also binds cholesterol
>> although fruits and grains don't contain
cholesterol. So very interesting, but
nevertheless, let's leave it at that.
Let's not go into too much detail. You
know, it's just it brings it back to a
whole food.
>> You have to have a whole food diet,
>> a whole apple or a whole
>> So when God puts sugar into it, he puts
fiber into it. And the more sugar there
is in it, the more fiber there is in it.
So the sugar rich foods, let's take a
date.
>> Yeah.
>> If you handle it, what's it feel like?
>> Yeah. Sticky.
>> It's tacky and sticky. What's making it
tacky and sticky?
>> The soluble fiber. Ah the soluble fiber
has a weak binding to the sugar.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> So that when you eat it, the sugar isn't
released immediately because it binds
it.
>> So that means it it releases it
proportionally.
>> So as it goes down your gut, there's a
slow release of glucose.
That is why it is very advantageous to
have a high fiber containing sugar.
Fruit for example when you are doing
sport or whether you are doing heavy
labor
>> a date or a banana is excellent. That's
a whole food. It's very high in sugar.
You can't just blame sugar.
>> No,
>> you have to buy have to blame the
refined food.
>> That's very important. So you see
because people don't know the whole
thing they tend to just focus on a small
thing and then ah we've got it
>> and they jump to confusions.
>> I think it's just important from what I
mentioned earlier that we must just talk
about Kellogg for a second.
He grew up or he stayed with Ellen
White.
>> Yes.
>> For a very long time. She was very fond
of him and she wrote many many letters
to him.
>> Yes. Yes. Did he get letters of
commendation for his early work?
Absolutely.
>> Did he get le letters of rebuke?
>> And that's the thing that we have to
talk about because it didn't end well
with Kellogg and the Adventist church.
>> Correct. Now Kellogg himself was the
medical doctor. It's really his brother
that started the the grain industry. And
that industry
kept Americans very healthy. She's
talking about the '9s when this changed.
Now before that, I would like to ask
them,
it's not a good thing to look at Jesuit
theater and at movies, but just look at
some of the old movies. Let's say movies
from the 50s and 60s
and look at those movies and tell me
whether you see obese people walking
around in those movies.
>> No, they don't exist. Everybody is slim.
Everybody is
>> But you can even look at photos or
videos that you see not even in a movie
of street um activity during that period
or so on.
>> You can have a look at it. There was no
obesity issue in the United States up
until after the 60s. What happened then?
Did the Adventists bring visions of
disease into the world? Absolutely not.
After the 60s, what happened? The
industry started refining foods more and
more and making them palatable for the
human consumption. So you have the corn
syrups coming into existence, high
sugar, no fiber, you have the refined
food industry and you have a total
disaster
and that led to the spikes in diabetes
and disease. Not the Adventists
>> salt levels were increased beyond any
health.
>> Exactly. anything that would make it
slide
>> down your throat rather than having to
chew it to get it down
>> and then you gulp it down with some more
sugar.
>> How how fast can you consume a modern
burger?
>> Yeah.
>> There's no fiber in it.
>> That's why they can some of these guys
can eat 20.
>> You can you can shove them. Have you
watched some of those eating
competitions how those burgers go down?
Try and do that with a whole food
burger. You'll choke
>> after the second one. And I like to see
how they look.
>> Exactly. So when it comes to plant-based
burgers, as she was referring to, those
were whole food.
>> They were made from legumes,
which is a seedbearing plant. Uh did the
Bible recommend that?
>> Mhm.
>> For sure.
>> So basically what she re recommended was
a biblicalbased diet. And in my
research,
whenever I did experiments to compare a
biblical whole food plant-based diet to
any modern diet or any diet rich in
animal proteins, the differences were
astounding.
And therefore, what she is saying is
totally incorrect. And she's only
talking about one catalog and not about
two cataloges. and two industries, the
one in the medical field and one in the
food production industry, but it was
designed to bring whole food, whole
grain to the people rather than refined
foods. And uh this worked until the
industry started manipulating food and
introducing components to make people
dependent
>> and addictive. Why would you want why
would you want to eat this instead of
bacon and eggs that they were eating?
Well, a lot of that is because of the
Seventh Day Advantist. They had secured
appointments within dietary
organizations in the government for
decades. One of them was Lennena Cooper.
She was a protege of Kellogg and his
wife. The Kelloggs had a cooking school
and their students went on to develop
nursing schools focused on nutrition.
Cooper graduated from one of those and
went on to establish the American
Dietetic Association. She served as on
the staff of the surgeon general and she
created the department of dietetics at
the National Institute of Health. Uh
there are many other 7th Day Adventists
who would then continue to influence the
plant-based diet. Uh like this guy Harry
Miller, he was also a Seventh Day
Adventist and a missionary in China.
That's how he came up with the idea of
soy milk. Did you know that that that
came from a a Chinese missionary, an
American missionary in China? Now, this
influence continues all the way through
until in 1988, the American Dietary
Association issued a formal acceptance
of vegetarianism.
Of the nine reviewers on that board,
eight of them were vegetarians, five
were 7th Day Adventists. Uh the other
three were vegetarians, but not
religiously associated. and one was not
a vegetarian, but he was funded by
Coca-Cola. And then we get this four
years later, the original USDA food
pyramid in 1992. Now, I'm not saying
that the Seventh Day Adventists were the
only influence in the government
development of that monstrosity. There
were other stories to be told, but we
know those stories. We're told them a
lot. The sugar lobby, the soda lobby,
the seed lobby, who benefited from that?
We know those stories. This one I feel
like most of us really don't like. What
about you boys? Did you guys know this
about Kelloggs?
>> Yes. I mean I I took a nutrition class
in college like a
>> Okay. Specifically
>> I watched a documentary.
>> So Martin if there were Adventists in
committees that advocated a plant-based
diet and she quoted a book earlier about
this hoax of a plant-based diet. Well,
then the original diet of man was also a
hoax.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh the change from one to the other
for me personally, I changed to
plant-based
38 years, 39 years ago.
>> If I had not changed, I can guarantee I
would have been dead already.
>> Oh, for sure.
>> Absolutely.
>> Because of the lifestyle that
>> Because of the lifestyle. Now when she
speaks about the great lobbies out
there, the sugar lobby and the oil seed
lobby, uh what are the dangers of these
foods?
>> Adventists
consistently
advocate a whole food unmanipulated
plant diet. Right,
>> that's it.
>> The oils are being manipulated. They are
heat extracted
and as such they oxidize.
Oils should be coldressed oils and
should have the original
composition that they had before. Not
chemically extracted like many of these
oils nor hydrogenated to make them into
butters or anything like that. These are
manipulations which are contrary to the
principles of health. So whole food
unmipulated
unadulterated oils. And what is the oil
that is recommended uh by the seventh
day adventist and by the prophet of the
seventh day adventist? Isn't that olive
oil?
>> Olive oil.
>> Fine. And what about soy milk?
>> That's the thing that you showed there.
>> Is is that evil? I I cannot why would
they dis
uh soy milk? Why would they do that?
Because soy milk if done correctly is
healthy
>> is absolutely
very healthy for you.
>> Exactly. So all of these arguments are
totally irrelevant. Now the the changes
that came in that pyramid were not
instituted by seventh day adventists or
propagated by any of the pioneers. It
was always a whole food diet. Stick to
what God had made. You can make food
palatable.
Ellen G. White wrote, "God will give
culinary skill to his people to make
food palatable so that it is pleasant to
the taste, but that it is un adulterated
in terms of refinement.
>> You can add things to food. You can add
a little bit of salt. You can add a
little bit of of herbs. You can add some
some interesting flavors to your food
and make them palatable as long as
they're whole foods." Now, over and over
and over again,
science has demonstrated that animal
products are unhealthy to the human
system. There are thousands of
publications. She's sweeping that whole
scientific plethora down from the table
and saying that was all the fault of the
Seventh Day Adventist. Well, they they
also state that um
companies that are involved. You see,
that's the thing. Now, they want they
they also like she stated who was
funding those experiments and those then
they came to the conclusion that only
the funding dictated what the outcome of
the seventh day Adventist companies. By
the way, most of the Seventh Day
Adventist companies have been sold to
secular companies.
>> Unfortunately, the same with
>> if they hadn't, they would still be
healthy.
>> The same with our health institutions
with, you know, the problem is if you
really want to know what the Seventh Day
Adventists believe on this diet issue,
go and read Councils on Diet and Food
and the Ministry of Healing.
>> Yes. Don't read somebody's book that he
wrote. Don't read that. Then you will
find out what the seventh adventists are
supposed to think on the issue. Okay,
let's move to a little bit of a another
issue.
She is now blaming all of this on the
Seventh Day Adventists.
The Seventh Day Adventists, as we have
said, advocate a whole food diet,
plant-based.
That is the best diet. And Originally
it was agreed or it was permitted that
certain animal products could be
included but there is a warning in the
spirit of prophecy that uh these were
never the best of foods
>> and that they should be progressively
excluded from the diet
>> of God's people right so even milk and
eggs and etc will be given up now how
How many food scares does she want?
Dairy food scares, egg shortages because
of Salmonella outbreaks or whatever kind
of disease there is.
>> We currently have that huge foot and
mouth outbreak in South Africa. No
farmers can sell any of the kettle
>> and they've killed hundreds of thousands
of them and those prophecies have all
come to fulfillment. But besides that,
let's take an independent study, the
China study. Yeah,
>> it was the most comprehensive study ever
done in humanity. Nothing to do with
Seventh Day Adventists.
And Dr. Campbell was responsible for
that study. And a huge series, Forks
Over Knives, came out as a consequence
of that study. And in that study, every
single thing that is written in the
writings of Ellen G. White was
corroborated.
I myself as a scientist and a
nutritional scientist and a professor of
medical bioscience had a long interview
with Dr. Campbell and that interview is
available on the internet. People can
watch it where he was astounded about
the similarities and these issues. He
didn't know of you.
>> He didn't know me and I didn't know him.
But at the basically the same time, the
experiments and the studies that you
guys were doing had the same answers.
>> The same answers. So I don't know where
she gets her information. The book that
calls this a scam or a hoax, the
plant-based diet is unfortunately
incredibly misinformed.
>> Yeah. Unfortunately, you've got now the
carnivore diet as well. Now obviously
the carnivore diet cuts out all the
same. There is refined foods and all of
this and a lot of people say they feel
better and they obviously you will when
you cut out all those things the same.
We've got a a center verity center a
health center. Yes. And I would
encourage people go and have a look at
the website. We've got wonderful reviews
and this is not the first time since the
1800s when yes Kellok had the
sanitarium. This was implemented and
people from all walks of life with all
sorts of diseases with this biblical
diet
>> have been cured
>> have been cured. Let's continue.
>> Yes. Yes. I mean, I I took a nutrition
class in college, like a Okay.
>> specific.
>> I watched a documentary.
>> A documentary. Okay. All right. So, this
is something that maybe some of you
know, but some of you might not. Now,
did you also know though that uh the 7th
Day Adventists still own quite a few
food brands, uh, including Sanitarium,
which is the largest cereal producer in
Australia. They make Weedabix. You might
have heard of this. Australians like to
talk about Weedabix. Uh, they also make
Vegemite, as in he just smiled and gave
me a Vegomite sandwich. That's what this
is. It's made by the Seventh Day
Adventists who believe that you
shouldn't eat meat because of the
temperance movement. Um, in the US, they
own Worthington, which makes plant-based
sandwich meats, and Cedar Lake, which
makes beans, rice, and uh, sugar, and
coffee. Now, most of these companies
don't have to pay taxes because they're
on their profits because they're owned
by a church. Uh, the vegetarian diet is
still very much out outwardly promoted
by the 7th day Advantist. Here's their
website. Now, what people may not know,
not only in their influence in the
American uh diet, but also in sort of
overreaching in in all areas of American
healthcare because they run large
hospital systems still such as the
Advent Health, which is really big here
in Colorado. David, you've seen it,
right? These these Advent Health is one
of the biggest health systems. That's
Did you know that's owned by the
Adventists?
>> I did not.
>> Yes, it is. Um they also run advers uh
universities, medical schools, research
centers. Uh they publish peer reviewed
research and nutrition. They have still
quite a lot of influence in public
health.
>> That is the most amazing thing that I've
ever heard. It seems to be a derogatory
thing and an evil thing to run health
centers and to try and help people to
live healthy lifestyles and to publish
peerreed literature on the subject
whereas everybody else is supposed to do
that and uh but now it's evil because it
comes from the seventh day adventist.
You were saying we run a health center,
right?
>> Are we doing it for profit?
>> No, we not at all. Not at all.
>> If we had to do it for a profit, then it
wouldn't exist.
>> It wouldn't exist or we'd have to run it
in a different way. We would have to
make it palatable. But we try to run it
in a way that uh educates people as to
what a healthy lifestyle is rather than
a condemnation. Shouldn't this be a
recommendation?
>> Well, that's the thing. If you go one of
the universities and I think she maybe
mentioning it later is Lom Minda and
Lominda has got one of the community is
one of the only blue zones in America.
>> Other words the the the greatest
longevity in the whole of the United
States rather than looking at what has
been positively achieved. They're trying
to turn the positive into a negative.
This is a very serious thing.
>> It's very serious. So maybe there are
some of the institutions of some of
these hospitals that are not adhering
completely to what was written by the
prophet and what is supposed to
>> that's not that's not the original
Adventist church's problem.
>> Some of these have become affiliated
with uh secular ones or Roman Catholic
ones or whatever. The Roman Catholic
Church also runs hospitals and
institutions. But the Roman Catholic
Church doesn't have a health message.
>> No. the Seventh Day Adventist has a
health message and thank God it has a
health message. It's not a negative,
it's a positive. And by the way, some of
these industries that she refers to that
belong to Seventh Day Adventist, most of
them have been sold. Uh in South Africa,
for example, uh a company by the name of
Pocoma is the company that produces and
sells wheat pickicss.
>> Mhm. and conf
>> in Australia, it might still be in the
hands of of the Adventists. But the
alternative foods, well, excellent. If
they want to use uh beef extracts, which
are made from the most horrendous
portions of animals uh with all their
associated problems, or rather have one
that is made from a plant extract. Thank
you very much. I'll choose the plant
extract. Everybody is welcome to choose
what they want, but I'm very glad that
there is a choice so that I can have one
that is healthier over one that has
maybe some other problems or issues in
it.
>> So, this is not a very good argument and
really they should uh they should have a
look at what they said. They actually
owe the Adventists an apology of
>> still quite a lot of influence in public
health. Um now, I'm not saying maybe
they don't believe this. They probably
really do, right? But this is their it's
it's their underlying religious
philosophy that's influencing their
research and products and then is
put on the American consumer whether we
know it or not. So this is a story worth
telling because the Adventist church
population is quite small. It's about
1.2 to 1.3 million members. It's about
the size of like Jehovah's Witnesses.
It's it's a small portion of the
American population that I estimate that
at about 04% of Americans, but they have
such
disproportional influence in dietary
decisions in the US government and
healthc care decisions. So
>> maybe we can just add here that the
Adventist is a worldwide church.
>> Yes, Adventist Church is a worldwide
church and by the way it's the only
Protestant worldwide denomination.
>> Yeah.
country. There are only two worldwide
denominations and that's the Roman
Catholic Church and the 7th Day
Adventist Church. The Roman Catholic
Church has absolutely zero influence on
the health of individuals. The
Adventists do. What do you prefer?
Someone who's concerned about your
health or someone who's not concerned
about your health? someone who preaches
a biblicalbased doctrine including uh
biblical doctrines such as the seventh
day Sabbath day whereas the others
advocate a pagan day and want to make
that the mark of their ecclesiastical
authority. What do you prefer a
Bible-based organization or a
traditionbased organization?
>> And also, did you know that the Seventh
Adventists are the fastest growing
Protestant denomination in the world? In
any case,
>> yes. And why are they growing? Because
they're Bible based.
>> Yeah.
>> And there's about two 22 million in the
world, not just 1.2 million.
>> That is the official number.
>> Oh yeah, for sure.
>> When you take government census, then
the number could be of at least those
that associate themselves with Seventh
Day Adventist up to 65 million.
>> Yeah. You know, it's interesting to know
that uh this is a story worth knowing
when you hear the government pushing
vegetarian and grain-based diets. Where
is that influence coming from? Now, RFK
Jr. has chosen not to do that. Um and
you know what he says is more
evidence-based food pyramid. But how do
we know that the current food pyramid
now is not shaped by profit or
ideological pressures? Well, we don't.
Not with certainty. What we do know is
that human beings do require complete
proteins, bioavailable fats, and
essential micronutrients for growth,
repair, and metabolic function. And this
pyramid does clearly have promote those
things instead of processed foods. So,
we can feel better about that. But will
there be people who profit from this
shift? Well, almost certainly. That's
why this scrutiny shouldn't just stop
because of these new guidelines. We
should always be paying attention to who
benefits and what power they yield. So,
let me know what you think of this in
the comments uh and if this is a story
you'd ever heard before.
>> Well, Martin, we just had answered her
question and let us know what we think.
>> Yeah. And by the way, when she made that
quip about complete proteins,
>> any grain plus a legume seedbearing is a
complete protein of a much better
quality than you can ever get from an
animal product.
>> How do you know that?
>> I've done it. I've done numerous
experiments on that in the lab. We have
published data. Our information is
published in peer-reviewed journals by
the way.
>> Not influenced by uh anybody with an
agenda.
>> No, not at all. Just a plain simple
experiment trying to find out which one
is better, the plant-based or the other
one. The plant-based always comes out on
top. And by the way, if you want healthy
oils, then the oils that you get in the
seeds and the oils that you get in the
olive is an extremely healthy oil. Once
you start extracting it, you have to
start to be careful. Uh an olive oil
once extracted as a cold pressed oil
will oxidate 10,000 times slower than a
polyunsaturated oil. And because the
polyunsaturated
oils are cheaper to produce, the
industry focuses on them, manipulates
them, refineses them beyond recognition
that they're not even foods anymore once
they're hydrogenated, for example, to
increase their self shelf life. Now, why
does it increase the shelf life? Because
not even bacteria can use it. That's why
it's not a food for human consumption.
Everything that is that is prepared out
there in the interest industry is
prepared with cheap extracted
polyunsaturated oils. Those are
unhealthy. So who's making the money
here and where's the money trail going
to? Uh the oils that you can use are
clearly stipulated in the in the Bible
and in the spirit of prophecy. If you
want to have healthy oils that have a
good ratio of omega-3 to omega6, then
you are talking about olive oil. You are
talking about macadamia oil, you are
talking about linseed oil, flax seed
oil, if you want to call it the American
way. Uh so those are oils that give you
a wellbalanced diet. They say you must
use the oils that uh come from fish for
example. Well, fish is rich in omega-3.
Yes. But it's icyosa pentaninoic acid
rather than the natural oils that you
find in plant-based foods, the linolinic
and the linoleic. One of which is is
omega3 and one is omega6. So there you
have the oils. They're all in there. By
the way, Martin, elephants
>> or all the animals out there that are
grazers and uh herbivores,
they seem to be weak and miserable
creatures without all these animal
products. Are they the strongest animals
in the world?
>> I've heard once argument that yes, but
they don't have the same digestive
system, but some of them do, don't they?
Um well the herbivores some of them have
rumins and they have bacterial
fermentation and all of these issues but
the product which they are getting is
plant-based and everything that the
bacteria in them use comes from the
plant-based
etc. So Martin, this argument is
ridiculous. And a plant-based diet is
the best diet, not only proven in the
world through studies like the China
study and many, many other studies of
similar nature, my own research, etc.
There's no doubt that the biblical
plant-based diet, the original diet is
the best for humanity. And any
organization Adventist or non adventist
that advocates it is a friend of
humanity.
So modern if we want to read a statement
on this issue from this prophet that is
so maligned in the world like all the
other prophets were in their times
uh one that had over 60 open visions so
that people could verify whether she was
fake or not. and then by the fruit
determine whether she was fake or not.
And does she take you to the word of God
or away from the word of God? Does she
say that we should have a creed? No. She
says we should have no creed. We should
have the Bible as our creed. It is the
standard for all correction and doctrine
in the world. Let's read what she says.
She says, "Perilous times are before us.
Everyone who has a knowledge of the
truth should awaken, place himself,
body, soul, and spirit under the
discipline of God. The enemy is on our
track. We must be wide awake and on our
guard against him. We must put on the
whole armor of God. The whole armor of
God is the scripture.
>> You have to be fortified with the word
of God. We must follow the directions
given in the spirit of prophecy. Whoa.
Did you know that, Martin? I know that
because I've read it.
>> If God speaks through a prophet and you
ignore it, don't you do it to the your
own peril?
>> Yes.
>> We must love and obey the truth for this
time. This will save us from accepting
strong delusions. God has spoken to us
through his word. He has spoken us
through the testimonies of the church
and through the books that have helped
to make plain our present duty and the
position that we should now occupy. The
warnings that have been given line upon
line, precept upon precept should be
heeded. If we disregard them, we what
excuse can we offer? People will have to
make a choice. I want to say if you
discard what she's written on health
then you have to pray that she's a false
prophet.
>> Oh I hope she's the false prophet then.
Yes.
>> But if you accept it
>> and
>> and do it will you have a benefit from
it?
>> I have I've received it myself.
>> I've received myself.
>> You've 39 years. My colleagues, I know
more dead people than I know living
people at this particular stage in my
life, which is rather sad. And uh my
colleagues
that were my my peers at the time,
well, Martin, most of them are under the
ground at the moment. And thank God that
I had an opportunity to change my
lifestyle. And by the way, I'm not
suffering as a consequence. I'm enjoying
it.
>> Oh, for sure. So may God help people to
make informed choices.
But false information like this will
become more and more and more prevalent
in the world. And the seventh day
Adventists will become the pariah.
>> They will become the enemy.
>> The the spirit of prophecy said seventh
day Adventist would not always be in the
news.
>> But that will not always stay like that.
>> No.
>> Look at what happened in this. If we
just bring in quickly the Charlie Kirk
thing, the Sabbath has been brought to
prominence,
this health thing, Seventh Adventist, we
saw in the previous episode, Seventh Day
Adventist being mentioned directly
against the Christian nationalist
movement.
>> Yes,
>> we are there.
>> We are there. The confrontation,
let's make it quite plain again, is
really a clash of minds.
So
we have two independent ministries
uh two internet broadcasting
organizations
broadcasting
two different views on the issue and
that's good so people can make a choice.
Choose thee this day whom you will
serve. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
everything that is standing in the word
is a subject of dispute. And it's been
like that ever since the fall of Lucifer
in heaven. The word of God, the word of
God that comes out of the mouth of the
Lord is being disputed at every single
level. Whether it be on the issue of
health or whether it be on the issue of
doctrine and the plan of salvation.
Oh Lord, we want to cling to what it
says in the word to be word-based to
believe a thus says the Lord. This is my
prayer in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
Heat. Heat.